- Welcome back, I'm hanging
out with Idina Menzel.
Give it up!
(audience clapping and cheering)
So the New York Times calls our next guest
Magic's Best Kept Secret,
which is saying a lot
because, well, it's magic.
He's collaborated with David,
See what I did there?
(chuckling)
He's collaborated with
David Blaine for 15 years
to create some of his most
mind bending illusions.
And now he has his own off-Broadway show
called David Blaine Presents
Asi Wind's Inner Circle.
Everybody say hi to Asi Wind.
(audience cheering and clapping)
Meet Idina.
So, I love magic, so I'm
very, very, very excited.
Okay, so David Blaine says
that you're his favorite magician.
That's a lot of weight
to carry; that's awesome.
- I know!
But so it happens he's
my favorite magician too.
I mean, he pushed the limits of magic
over the last 15, 20
years and became my hero.
And now I'm honored that
he's presenting my show.
It's amazing.
- Yeah, it's so cool.
I love that you both have
such a fond respect of each other.
That's so cool.
So what are you showing us today?
I see cards.
- Let's warm up.
Let's warm up.
- Exactly right. So can
I ask you this question?
If you can just name a
favorite card or random card.
- [Kelly] Queen of hearts.
- The which?
- Queen of hearts.
- Okay, I do this.
(card deck slapping)
- Okay.
(fingers snapping)
- Reach into my pocket.
- No way.
- Go for it.
- I will slap you.
(audience and Idina laughing)
- No way.
(gasps)
(screams)
(audience clapping and cheering)
(Asi laughing)
- That's amazing.
- How would you have done
that with slight of hand
or like I don't even
understand how that, what?
- Should we try something crazier?
- 100 percent.
- Okay, let's do it.
I don't assume.
Do you don't have bills on
you or purse or something?
I need like a -
- Do we look like strippers?
(audience laughing)
No, I don't, but I can
ask someone for money.
Wouldn't it be amazing if
I just pulled some out?
- [Asi] I would be shocked.
- Can I have some money, Chris?
Do you got any money?
- [Chris] I got money.
- Come on, Chris.
- Like at least four, five, six bills.
Something like, yeah.
Yeah, put it here if you don't mind.
- Okay, just like this?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Okay.
- So here's what I'd like you to do.
- Thanks, Chris.
- I would like you,
first of all, how many
bills do we have here?
- [Kelly] All right, Chris.
- [Asi] Wow. Look at that!
- It's a nice variety,
it's a really nice variety.
Can you please, Idina,
please put your finger right there.
And Kelly name a number
between one and five.
Just say it out.
(fingers snapping)
- Four!
- Four.
Okay. So take the fourth bill down.
One.
- [Idina] One.
- [Asi] Two
- [Idina] Two.
Three.
- [Asi] Three.
Four.
- [Asi] And the fourth one,
I don't wanna see it, just fold it.
Yeah, take the fourth bill.
Yeah, take it out.
- [Idina] Take it out?
- [Asi] And fold it a few times.
The rest of them we'll put aside.
You remind me.
- Okay.
(audience and Kelly laughing)
- [Chris] Hey, hey!
- I know, I know, I get it.
- [Idina] That's a lot of money in there.
- It's how you get paid. I got it.
- Kelly, as I drop cards onto the table,
you call the word stop.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Okay. I'll do it again.
- Okay.
- Okay means stop?
Or we'll do it again?
- Oh! Oh! I'll say stop.
- Okay so -
- Stop!
- [Asi] Look, if you say
add two more, three more,
I will do it.
Unless you like it here.
- I like it there.
- No more? Not one more,
two more, three more,
five more, whatever you want?
- No, I want that one.
- Say the word stop.
- [Kelly] Stop!
- [Asi] That's good?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Asi] And one last
time say the word stop.
- [Kelly] Stop.
- [Kelly] So all of these,
because you said stop, go away.
Between those four piles,
one, two, three, and four,
I want you to turn one
over and you turn one over.
Face down.
- [Kelly] Just turn one over, like this?
- [Asi] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
The whole pile.
- [Kelly] Oh, okay!
- [Asi] You can do the whole pile.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- [Asi] And you, the whole pile.
So now we have cards going
face up and face down.
- So excited! Okay.
- [Asi] Hold on, it's getting better.
(Idina laughing)
So can you push these into these? Push.
- [Kelly] Push them.
- [Asi] Push it like that.
So now you can see we need,
don't square anything,
but you can see cards going
different ways, right?
- [Idina] Yes.
- [Asi] Different ways.
Between these two piles.
Should we turn this over or these over?
It's up to you.
- Turn those over.
- So all of these will be
turned this way, right?
- Okay.
- Can you push these into these?
- [Kelly] I just like how
you say it with your accent.
That's so cool.
- I fake it, just it looks more authentic.
(all laughing)
It's really cool.
- I like it.
- Usually it's American.
- Okay.
Last time.
This one or this one?
- [Kelly] That one.
- Interesting.
- Okay?
(Idina chuckles)
- What does it say about Kelly?
It's like handwriting analysis.
- I went with less is more.
- Yeah, it's interesting.
I like that approach.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- [Asi] Can you push these into these?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Asi] Push these into these.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- [Asi] You agree that's a mess
- [Kelly] Yeah, chaotic, chaos.
- I want you to look close
as I just square the deck.
Just square the deck like this.
- [Kelly] Don't know what's happening.
- [Asi] And look what's gonna happen.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- [Asi] I'm gonna make
every single card in here
go face down.
Meaning I'll fix every card.
- Okay.
- Ready?
- How?
- Watch.
(card deck flipping)
That's it. Every card will, hold on,
cause I see they're face up still.
(hand clapping)
That's it.
(Idina laughing)
- What?
- All of them are now face down.
- But I see the white.
- Really? Let me see.
- [Kelly] Wait, what do you
mean? Wait, what do you mean?
Wait, what do you mean?
- No, what I meant to say
is that most of them are face down.
(audience laughing)
- [Asi] It's what? It's
six, seven, eight cards?!
Kelly, Kelly.
- Totally.
- This is where I get nervous.
Like, did this come out wrong,
and you want us to start over?
- Let me tell you something.
In today's economy, that's pretty good.
- It's true.
- But hold on.
You shuffled them, face up, face down.
And I asked you all
along the way, how many,
and how many piles, and I
asked you to bring some bills.
These are your bills,
and you chose this bill.
You know this bill is unique.
Can I show you something?
This bill is unique because
it's a one of a kind.
This dollar bill does
not exist anywhere else,
because you see the serial
number is one of a kind.
(Kelly and Idina gasp)
So look at the number.
Can you read it out loud, Kelly?
- What?!
- [Asi] Seven. Read it, seven.
- [Kelly] Oh my god.
- [Asi and Kelly] Seven,
two, one, three, nine, five,
three, four.
- [Asi] Three and four.
- Oh my god.
(audience cheering)
- Thank you so much.
- That was incredible.
I can't stop, that was so mindblowing.
I love magic.
Oh my god.
Asi Wind, everybody, give it up.
(audience cheering)
Wow. If you're New York area,
you can see him live in person.
You will want to do this.
That was incredible.
His new show is called
Asi Wind's Inner Circle.